what is the role that creativity plays
in an organization or a business or an
industry that people don't typically
think of as being creative it's clear
that people would consider the Arts and
film and writing forth to be creative so
that's clear I think most people would
say that if you're designing products
that's creative but they kind of stop
around there personally I believe
solving problems is creative so if you
got problems in your family or in your
neighborhood and you're able to work
come out with people that's a creative
act and I think that creating an
organization that is better for people
and that brings the best out of them is
a creative act also I look at a lot of
what I've done is like trying to solve
the problems you know it's actually the
the bigger contribution i' I've had
because the original thing that I did
like that it's can to happen anyway but
trying to create a culture well that
applies everywhere